the community of Columbia South Carolina
is in mourning after fourteen-year-old
Cyrus Carmack Belton was fatally shot
after leaving this gas station Sunday
evening he's scary
senseless
according to the sheriff Carmack Belton
entered the store around 8 pm and took
water bottles from a cooler before
putting them back police say the store's
owner 58-year-old Rick Chao has said he
thought the teenager was stealing after
they argued Carmack Belton exited the
store and was chased down the street by
chow and his son then Chao observed what
looked to be a firearm pulled out his
Glock and fired one shot hitting the 14
year old in the back piercing his heart
a gun believed to be the boys was also
found at the scene he was running away
he was shot in the back he never pointed
a gun at anybody